terça feira que vem dia 18
faz dois anos exatamente o que eu casei
pela sexta vez com o mesmo marido
eu explico é que para o marco o dia em
que ele decidiu casar comigo e o dia da
mudança do status do facebook também
contam
ele é um pouco exagerado mas o fato é
que foram muitos casamentos e dois deles
foram em viamão
o primeiro foi um tratamento espiritual
a gente veio para um retiro em um
carnaval e fizeram um casamento surpresa
para nós
sim existe casamento surpresa não é só o
aniversário surpresa e pra mim foi o
casamento que mais valeu foi o mais
intenso assim foi muito doido
depois teve o casamento civil igreja
católica para não ficar chato pra
família e finalmente a gente fez uma
festa para os amigos e para a família
que afinal eles deveriam saber que a
gente casou né
e também foi em viamão então vi a mão é
muito simbólico pra mim tem uma história
de resgate de inesperado nunca imaginei
que minha história vai se passar por
viamão não conhecia praticamente viamão
e hoje eu tô aqui então isso é bem
simbólico e na verdade o fruto desses
casamentos todos também está aqui que é
carolina que é a minha pequena grande
professora
na verdade a carolina tem inspirado
muito e me ajudado a resgatar a minha
criança interna ea me enxergar como uma
boa curiosa observadora que eu sou
e é isso que eu vim contar pra vocês um
pouquinho dessa andréia curiosa que está
enxergando umas coisas bacanas por aí
como miguel falou eu sou comunicadora
mas eu sou um monte de coisa e eu tenho
descoberto que eu sou uma boa conector
de gente eu coloco pessoas interessantes
em contato e da coisa boa e eu converso
com muita gente dentro e fora das
empresas
muita gente na verdade o governo meio
psicóloga sem querer assim isso é bem
bacana e o que dá pra ver é que
independente da gente estar vestindo uma
roupa corporativa
nós somos em essência os mesmos seres
humanos em busca de uma razão da nossa
existência
esse é o maior que a gente comentou
antes ele acontece independente se eu
toco meu crachá ou não e parece que
existe um botãozinho de liga e desliga e
não é verdade gente tá tudo conectado
essa história que nos falam de
interdependência à parte o todo o
rede
faz sentido de verdade está não é
brincadeira não
o que eu tenho visto por aí é um grande
vazio existencial de pessoas
independente das empresas
eu tenho o privilégio de conviver com
gente de m tipos e de idades diferentes
momentos de vida diferentes
eu conheço por exemplo muito presidente
de empresa senhores com seus sessenta e
poucos anos 70 anos que chegaram lá no
topo
eles têm dinheiro eles têm status eles
têm um cargo deles tem um vazio enorme
dentro deles eu tenho acessam a meninos
prodígios de 20 anos que estão super
inquietos que querem fazer alguma coisa
diferente eles querem empreender
eles não têm orgulho daquilo que os pais
fizeram não quero não querem construir o
mundo igual que os pais fizeram mas eles
não sabem o que fazer
eles também têm um grande vazio tem uma
pessoa que eu tenho conversado muito que
tem me ajudado a entender essas coisas
que é oswaldo oliveira o cara das redes
que a gente fala e oswaldo me conta uma
história bem bacanas que tem outros
vazios por aí que tem tudo a ver com
coisas que foram ditas hoje por exemplo
artistas que tiveram a coragem de viver
as suas artes desde muito cedo e que não
fizeram o pé de meia e que chegar nos 60
anos estão arrependidos porque não tendo
que viver
por outro lado tem os grandes
empreendedores grandes profissionais que
estão fazendo o pé de meia para um dia
serem artistas e eles também não chegam
lá alguns enfartam antes e tal
então a sensação que eu tenho é que não
é ou é e que a gente não pode ficar
esperando pra fazer isso e tem coisas
que não nos contam também tem coisas que
a gente tem feito no automático
aliás a gente tem vivido muito
automático né por exemplo quando a gente
vai abrir uma empresa
a gente faz um contrato social nós
deveríamos ter uma razão social para
existir enquanto empresas
aliás nós deveríamos ter uma razão para
existirmos enquanto pessoas também seria
legal ea gente pega vou abrir uma
empresa eu vou na automática o chamam
advogado faça aquela parte burocrática
super chata eu coloco ali uma razão
social social quer e eu nunca paro
a pensar que razão é essa que me faz ter
vontade de abrir uma empresa com todas
as dificuldades importa os problemas e
tal e eu esqueço que estou falando de
pessoas e que eu vou trabalhar para
pessoas
a razão social o contrato social é um
contrato que eu faço para a sociedade
outra coisa que nos contam né parece que
estar dentro de uma empresa hoje em dia
é feio é pecado é bicho papão como se só
o que tem lá fora é legal então eu tenho
falado com muita gente que está cansado
das dívidas corporativas que querem
empreender
eu vou chutar o balde vou largar tudo e
vou ser feliz lá fora a gente lá fora e
aqui dentro são a mesma coisa
as empresas são espelhos das nossas
almas que estão inquietos estão
inseguras estão com medo
eu não vou dizer que todas as empresas
sejam realmente maravilhosas enxerga
muita coisa complicada e eu acho que tem
muita gente que realmente não deve
colocar energia em algumas empresas que
são predadoras de fato mas por que não
tentar empreender dentro de uma empresa
de uma estrutura que já existe e tentar
seu agente transformador dessa empresa
então acho que tem algumas coisas que
estão mal contadas que estão erradas
dentro dessa história surge um pouco do
tema que me convidaram pra falar hoje
que é o tal do lucro admirado e merecido
nossa andré como assim está falando uma
coisa que é pecado lucro é pecado vai
pro inferno quem tiver lucro
desculpa gente não é assim há uns 20
anos surgiu um conceito que nunca esteve
tão atual
o josé carlos teixeira moreira que é um
consultório melhorar antes construíram
um conceito e tal que chamaram de
empresas válidas
segundo eles uma empresa é válida quando
é genuína quando as pessoas têm vontade
de verdade fazer alguma coisa bacana
quando dá orgulho de estar dentro
daquela história
dentro desse conceito de empresas vagas
eles criaram a constelação de valor que
são estrelinhas que fazem ajudam as
empresas a se tornar válida e uma dessas
estrelinhas é o tal do lucro admirado o
merecido como assim andréia lucro néné
quem vai lucrar e vai ser legal
lembrando as empresas são um pedaço da
gente nós empresas
a mesma coisa parte todo e tal quando
nós não estamos bem dinheiro por exemplo
estamos devendo e tal
a gente não pára de pé não é sustentável
ninguém fica bem devendo para o banco
ninguém fica feliz e tal no as partes da
gente a gente usa inclusive esse tipo de
terminologia nas nossas vidas pessoais
eu invisto em visto naquela relação e
não tá dando lucro
ou então estou me sentindo explorada eu
valho mais do que isso o ser humano em
uma forma nata ele precisa do
merecimento do reconhecimento e o
dinheiro faz parte disso
a gente sabe que a gente está vivendo
uma vida real e que eu não posso chegar
no restaurante cantar uma música popular
songs é uma pessoa muito legal e eu
acredito no mundo que não tenha dinheiro
tal então o fato não é esse o fato é
como eu faço pra minimamente ajudar a
construir uma empresa que quando lucre a
sociedade acha bacana
sabe aquele amigo legal que a gente tem
quando ele se dar bem na vida a gente
fica feliz porque a gente fica feliz ao
fulano se deu bem na vida ele estudou e
tal está com dinheiro que ele vai fazer
com aquele dinheiro ele vai fazer um
monte de coisa boa
ele vai viajar ele vai fazer outros
cursos ele vai crescer como pessoa então
esse conceito de lucro admirado essa
historinha que tem por aí faz sentido
nesse sentido na medida em que esse
dinheiro servir para reabastecer uma
energia vai reconstruir coisas que são
bacanas para retroalimentar essa cadeia
a gente está falando de uma vida real
então como é que eu faço isso
minimamente né
ah eu tenho visto gente muitas novas
empresas que são genuinamente
preocupados em fazerem coisas bacanas
eu diria para vocês que elas são poucas
porque a maioria das empresas está muito
perdida assim a máquina meio que comeu
as pessoas elas perderam um pouco de
senso mas eu diria para vocês que tem
gente aqui dentro está fazendo uma
revolução e limpeza empresas que são
tradicionais que teriam tudo para
estarem incomodados está acontecendo e
exige uma super coragem de fazer isso é
muito fácil eu tava ganhando com o meu
lucro e tal e eu tenho coragem para
começar isso começar do zero é mais
fácil mas existem sines
mas que fazem muito sentido e que estão
acontecendo de verdade ea gente pode
minimamente resgatando tudo que foi dito
aqui pegar nesses nossos sonhos internas
e ajudarmos a fazer isso acontecendo as
empresas e felizmente esperar que ela
sim lucro para que a gente possa
transformar esse lucro em coisas boas
então um pouco por aí eu acho que está
acontecendo que a grande desconstrução
que está sendo dito aqui hoje as coisas
que a gente tem visto é que está tudo
meio trocado não é eu existo para
trabalhar é eu trabalho também para
existir
eu também trabalho mas eu tenho outras
coisas o trabalho simplesmente ajuda a
que andré subsidiar um sonho com isso
ela ela tem dinheiro pra fazer coisas
mas não é só o financeiro que está em
jogo eo que mais se o trabalho não
realiza se o trabalho não se torna uma
pessoa melhor
troque por que em qualquer outro
trabalho de alguma forma a gente vai ser
remunerado para minimamente conseguir
ganhar aquilo que a gente precisa para
comprar as coisas básicas necessárias
não luxo
então eu acho que a grande questão essa
inversão de valores que está acontecendo
e como é que eu lido com elas mas então
como é que a gente faça andré como é que
eu sei se eu tenho uma empresa legal se
tem jeito
como é que eu construísse como é que
observo é esse caminho que eu estou
seguindo faz sentido mas que acorda de
manhã e vejo que não estou perdendo
tempo eu tenho que realmente mudar
não adianta a gente pensar de um jeito
racional de novo né
imagina chegar à carolina ou você
chegarem às suas crianças internas que
estão adormecidas e bater um papo com
elas e conta a história do lucro
olha só minha filha a nossa empresa
lucrou x milhões esse ano isso é muito
bom para o mercado financeiro vai
movimentar as ações e tal
ela vai olhar vai falar ah mas existem
outros direitos a gente fazer isso e na
verdade esses são os grandes indicadores
que nos vão mostrar se aquilo que a
gente está fazendo faz sentido se esse
lucro ele é realmente admirado exceto
etc acrescenta sempre trabalha eu sou
uma pessoa válida se eu estou fazendo
sentido pra mim mesmo
começa a compensar a contar as coisas
que acontecem dentro dessa empresa
dentro desse mundo corporativo ou não
corporativo e começa a contar histórias
que como as pessoas
são as pessoas que estão lá dentro como
eu me sinto estando lá dentro e aí minha
gente o principal indicador vai ser o
tom que vocês tiverem contando eo jeito
que essa história vai começar a fazer
sentido pra vocês
se num determinado momento vocês pararem
e olharem da carolina de vocês as suas
crianças internas ea brilhar o olho
então tá tudo certo
é isso gente muito obrigado
[Aplausos]